we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P you know a lot of people
were concerned about my hair yesterday
saying David you know are you are you
having an alcohol problem are you having
something going on in your life where
your grooming is really falling apart
because sometimes when people are
struggling they're grooming suffers and
indeed here is someone who called in
about the cowlick
hey man how you doing James from Boston
um way back way back from the
Northampton Days please watching the
show as usual it's great as usual
and as usual you've got some giant
cowlick
jutting up from the back of the right
side of your head yes
um you know it is what it is I'm just
wondering like what what is going on
with your hair
um
it's just it's just watch it I'm trying
to watch the show it's just vaguely
distracted yeah so a lot of people wrote
To Me concerned here's what's going on
okay it's getting nice out
and it's late the light is out there's
light until late in the day and so very
often I'm not getting the opportunity to
shower until 9 pm and it's forcing me to
go to bed with wet hair
and then I wake up and it's a complete
and total mess and I understand that it
seems as though something really bad
must be going on for this to be
happening my grooming just suffering so
much but it's basically like with my
baby daughter's schedule and then you
know sometimes we'll we'll go out for a
drink and then it becomes 7 30 and then
it you know we go through bedtime
routine and then dinner and by the time
I'm able to shower it's nine and I'm
trying to get in bed by 10 15 these days
and get an earlier start so I'm going to
bed with wet hair now I know you could
say well David you could just use a blow
dryer I don't know how to use a blow
dryer so that's the problem with that
but everything is fine it's not an
alcohol related issue it's not anything
it's not an emotional issue I'm just
going to bed with wet hair because of my
schedule now that it's nice out
and that is what it is but I'll try to
keep things under better control on the
bonus show today we'll talk about what's
going on with Steven Crowder so many of
you writing to me we will discuss it we
will talk about the trans lawmaker
censured by the Montana House
Republicans we will talk about what's
going on with the founder of the we
build the wall scam group he got four
years in prison and so much more make
sure you have access to the bonus show
by signing up at joinpakman.com